hi welcome to another episode of cold
fusion where i cover anything in science
technology business or history
in a world that's growing increasingly
authoritarian a platform that grants
people the right to do and say what they
please is a rarity
amongst this backdrop telegram is a
distinct oddity it's commonly on the
list of the 10 largest platforms in the
world but has just around 30 core
employees they've had no ongoing source
of revenue until very recently and
telegram exercises virtually no content
moderation except legal content and
calls for violence
telegram markets itself as a company
platform that's available to all
regardless of politics or ideology
telegram's russian founder pavel durov
states quote for us telegram is an idea
it is the idea that everyone in this
planet has the right to be free
so what is telegram and who was its
founder and is it a safe platform to use
in this episode we'll take a look
you are watching telefusion tv
[Music]
for years now the world has fretted over
facebook now matters seemingly
unstoppable dominance the firm has
relentlessly neutralized its competitors
either by acquisition or elimination not
to mention the subjugation of politics
culture and every facet of intimate life
crushed and tossed around by the
priorities of an algorithm an algorithm
built for ad sales
escalating privacy scandals and
disingenuous apologies have only left a
sour taste in people's mouths
but recently in the past year or so mark
zuckerberg's empire has begun to look a
little more vulnerable lawmakers have
increasingly rallied against it
investors are losing confidence and
network outages have only made things
worse for the firm because of all of
this telegram with its tiny staff has
emerged as one of the greatest
beneficiaries of all of these stumbles
telegram gained a record 70 million new
users during a nearly six hour facebook
long outage in october
according to the specialist firm sensor
tower telegram became the fifth largest
downloaded app up from number 56 in the
united states
so what is telegram exactly
telegram is a chat instant messaging
service
the service also provides voice calling
file sharing and several other features
in january of 2021 telegram surpassed
500 million active users it was the most
downloaded app worldwide in january of
2021 with 1 billion downloads globally
in his early descriptions of telegram
founder pavel durov often cited edward
snowden's revelations about government
spyware and claimed that he made the app
over worries about government
surveillance in russia which is why
apart from the ordinary chat feature the
telegram messaging app also has a secret
chats function a function which uses
end-to-end encryption and stores
messages locally on user's devices
as we'll later see all may not be as it
seems with this feature
durov who was a fundamentalist
libertarian has for years faced off with
the kremlin's efforts to silence him in
his native country
russia he founded telegram with his
brother in 2013 as a digital outpost of
free speech after the kremlin stripped
him of control over vk a popular social
media site he created as a russian
version of facebook in which he was
co-founder in 2006
telegram has no ads or investors and is
funded almost entirely through durov's
personal fortune it is hosted on
multiple servers around the world
ensuring that no one government can
exercise total control or gain access to
information about users
the company's ownership structure is
also a bird's nest of shell companies
from belarus to hong kong telegram has
long been an engine of resistance and an
annoyance to tyrants all over the world
last august in belarus during the
presidential elections the government
shut down whatsapp twitter and facebook
but resistance spread through telegram
in iran telegram usage takes up 60
percent of the country's internet
bandwidth the app was a crucial platform
for organizing and spreading
anti-government protests in 2017 and
2019. currently the service is being
used to show what's happening in the
russia ukraine war
telegram is extremely popular in asia
latin america and increasingly in europe
as mentioned it remains free to users
with no advertisements but supporting
such a huge population of users isn't
cheap
durov had walked away from the last
company he founded vk with a reported
300 million
but for a long time he was still paying
for the operating costs of the app
himself
telegram needed a way to pay for its
soaring server costs so he turned to the
crypto industry
the idea was to leverage telegram's huge
user base to push cryptocurrencies
towards widespread adoption his thinking
was that a native platform currency
would be very disruptive
telegram then started working on
building a new blockchain platform
called the telegram open network or ton
they did this along with its own native
currency called grams
the system promised to be much faster
than current blockchain technology
the white paper promised millions of
transactions a second versus about 15
transactions a second with mainstream
crypto
telegram managed to do the biggest
initial coin offering in history at the
time 1.7 billion dollars from 175
investors but from the start there were
red flags
the offering was kept private and there
was little way of knowing who the
private investors were or where the
money had come from
as the official launch neared the u.s
securities and exchange commission
brought everything to a sudden halt
the sec claimed that the crypto network
would constitute the distribution of
unregistered securities they also
claimed that the company spent 90 of the
1.7 billion in paying off telegrams
expenses without ever distinguishing
between money spent on the app and on
their ton network
while telegram wanted a utopian vision
of a revolutionary fintech their rushed
launch brought it all to a premature end
while telegram has been vital to
pro-democracy protesters it's also worth
noting how poorly understood the app is
especially in the united states where
most journalists still refer to it as a
quote encrypted messaging app
this description unnerves many security
experts who warn the unlike signal
telegram is not end to end encrypted by
default
users must go out of their way to turn
on the app's secret chat function which
very few people actually do
and that only works for individual
conversations and not those among groups
so there's millions of people out there
who use telegram who think that no one
can see their messages but that's not
necessarily true
and this confusion could prove very
costly
[Music]
elias campo telegram's head of growth
business and partnerships in a recent
interview with wyatt has shed some
eye-opening facts about the internal
workings of telegram and its founder
quote we're portraying ourselves as a
company that's open that's supposed to
be for freedom of communication and
transparency between users and on the
other side we're completely opaque on
how we work
back in 2014 after facebook acquired
whatsapp camper had quit in protest
he believed that the social media
giant's addictive algorithms had a very
negative impact on humanity
yet at whatsapp as campo says every
single employee had access to data on
user numbers in different markets
at telegram if campo wanted stats he had
to explain why to his boss durov is
quote
very very very restrictive everything
has to go through him end quote
inside telegram campo further revealed
the company's inner circle of mainly
russian developers look upon their
leader as quote almost like a divine
figure and they never contradict him
currently campo is preparing to leave
telegram
lastly campo has hinted at the fact that
there was a chance that telegram could
monitor someone's private communications
as well
quote
technically it's possible to do so at
scale would be difficult but encryption
between a user and cloud server could
potentially be deactivated on a target
account i don't know if it's happening
or not
so in conclusion
while telegram does sell itself as the
app of privacy there may need to be some
more careful consideration in how it's
used
to me it's interesting to see how
facebook's shortcomings were so quickly
filled by a team of around only 30
people so what do you guys think about
telegram are you a person that uses it
or are you staying clear
so thanks everyone for watching and
supporting this channel over all the
years i feel like i don't say that
enough
feel free to check out the last cold
fusion episode on spinal implant
technology it's an interesting one and
is sure to warm your heart
so my name is dagogo and you've been
watching cold fusion and i'll catch you
again soon for the next episode
cheers guys
have a good one
[Music]
cold fusion
it's new thinking